be asking for for
um
so like the sore lab is done.
I have to test it again. That's why
that's a problem. But the the edits have
are done with it. I was like wow
actually have the sor lab and the waff
lab like
how much did I have on what was I doing?
Why was I on something like that?
>> I usually don't function that well. And
maybe I was studying for the Japan
intern or something like that. I'm just
kind of high and I just started doing
this stuff on the side. You
>> were you you wanted to have some fun
like you always say.
>> I'm having fun.
It doesn't sound like it, but
yeah, you're having fun.
>> It is.
So, there's a long way to go.
>> How How much? Well, long way to Okay.
Well, for you your I guess it's for your
goals and aspirations and whatnot. Yeah,
that's fair.
So yeah, the table update item. Yep.
Yep.
>> Okay.
>> Put that in there.
>> And that's why you have to have that the
the table name be the same.
>> Okay.
>> I would I remember that. That's why it
was so important because if you screw
this up, nothing works.
>> Oh. Oh. Because this is a reference.
Wait. Yeah.
>> table.update.
I don't
sit here.
All right.
So, I'm I guess we have to do the the
curl or Well, we should probably test
this first.
>> Yep. Test it first.
All right. Now, we'll deploy it. And
is there a node
um version of this
or
>> uh no no?
>> Okay.
All right. So,
>> and you're going to have to create
another lambda after this.
>> Okay. The detection lambda.
>> Yep.
>> Okay.
We just called.
This is going to be
all right. Everything looks good.
Oh, we don't even touch any of these.
So,
right.
Whatever.
Okay. This is it here.
Got
to do this now.
Right.
Looks like it's working.
Okay. What is next?
Okay.
Wait, which one? This is okay. Create
rule. So, this first one is fine.
Yep. Okay.
Okay. Interesting.
So, hold on. You're invent bridge,
right? Okay. Hold on. uh go back to your
um
uh what is it called? Uh GitHub. You're
following the GitHub instructions,
right?
>> Yes, it's on my other screen.
>> Yeah. Okay. Here, real quick, I want you
to refresh.
>> Okay.
>> Okay. Now, go back to the event bridge,
which is going to be part
five.
>> Yep.
>> Okay. Good. I just refreshed that so it
looked better. because that was I I was
reading through I was like, "Oh, that's
really hard to read." So just did it. So
and event bridge rules create rule and
then that's the name of the rule.
>> Okay.
>> All that all that type all the
information is needed.
>> All right, let's do it. Okay. Um I just
want to know is is this fun for
everybody?
>> This is interesting.
Um
>> well, it should be fun. Who who thinks
this is fun?
>> Yeah,
>> this is fun.
>> The the main thing you got I I think a
main thing that would help is explaining
well suggesting a a problem that this
solves.
>> Oh. Oh.
Yeah. It's believe me the detection of
the of a of a expired token
very valuable to companies extremely
invaluable because you don't want a
token that has that's unlimited
right it fails um compliance that's I
know it's called like bear token
something like that so you don't want
that
>> this is this is this for security this
is the bomb right uh anyway go back to
GitHub real
So
>> go back to GitHub. Put the GitHub back
on stream. It says, "Is this fun? Say
Leo loves me if this is fun for you." I
heard a lot of people say this is fun.
>> That's a trap.
>> Yeah, it's a trap.
>> I a trap. I'm just
I I I'm just saying, you know, I think
for a lot of people, Leisel loving you
is a good thing. All right.
I mean,
for for some people, they're just going
to they they'll cut the middle, man. Go
straight to Weasel. I don't know.
>> There you go. Yeah.
>> But but but yes,
>> this how you know it's like this is like
2 or 3 o'clock in the morning and Theo's
doing this.
But but it's but it is it is in this is
really good from a security and
compliance standpoint because you're
you're
when we the the prior infrastructure
we've had we're able to run it through
the W but and it it catches it in real
time but you still need historical data.
So you have historical data of the
tokens via the database which is good
and then in addition you have the
detection logic to see if a if a token
is expired. that it's really good. Um
mainly because if you could if you're
able to track
um whether a token expired or not and
you're able to do so in a serverless
fashion via API calls
that is directly in line with how AI is
working right now. So you can you have
authentication, you have authorization,
you're able to detect who's using what,
why, and and you know and if a session
has exceeded its time, you can then
create you can you can then you know
invalidate the session and and and uh
you know the W would act on said invalid
session saying hey you can't come in
because your time's up you got to
reauthenticate or whatever and this is a
really um this is a this is basically us
implementing
inline security for AI in runtime. So
it's really really strong.
>> You're describing the
>> my bad.
>> This is this is pretty much this is what
we're going in with sword. So this would
this would be a a a key component of
sword. um being able to do this with
this kind of infrastructure and being
able to have that you have the database,
right? So you have a uh tracking of
what's going on. You have historical
data in there, right? Um
bro,
like an auditor would come in and love
you guys if you guys
you'd pass audit to such a degree it it
wouldn't even be funny. And then of
course with the with the AI being in
there and then you also have run books
with there with bedrock. This is this is
like
this super valuable for companies who
know what they're doing like for E1s
E3s.
Yeah. They have budget. Oh yeah.
That's right. This is what we're doing.
Not just I see Carlton. See I know
something's going on.
>> Yes. So it's if a company knows what
they're talking about then
it's viable. the one line the one liner
I would suggest for you know your speech
also your resume also or whatever
>> we're we're we're implementing security
controls
to get more to have more uh uh uh we're
implementing security controls and I for
APIs in order to uh meet
audit standards
compliance.
>> Yeah. So, so you do this the first time,
right? So then
you have different customers, right? So
the different customers can be using
different tokens when they're
authenticating in and then it only lasts
a certain amount of time. So then you
have quality of service for these
tokens. So then that means you can
actually give a service out to somebody
and you can track whether how whether or
not the person authenticated, whether or
not they're can use the service and then
it makes sure that you don't have the
service have a session hijack. And if
there's no session hijack that means
they have to pay for the service every
time they use it.
That means you have a technical ability
to enforce
payment for a service.
Now, whatever that service is, I don't
care, but it could be anything. For
example, insurance claims,
um, prescription refilling,
um, buying music online, things like
this. You need a token every time.
digital transaction from a app using
like a like a wechathat,
>> right?
So, if you're able to track it with this
and actually do the enforcement,
then you're you're doing basically
quality of service for an e-commerce
site correctly, they will pay you money
for this. This is this is moolaf
or some people. And and you know, I'll
say this last thing and then we'll we'll
you know, I'll let Kevin keep working.
But uh I just saw an article or I just
saw Yes. saw a release talking about
AWS, Coinbase, and Stripe trying to work
together to create a a payment platform
that would enable AI agents to start
making payments. So
this is
this this will be essential.
>> Yeah. This this kind of architecture of
course they would probably do it a
little bit differently but just being
able to do this and understand how this
is working. Oh yeah you're good.
So you got define. Okay. So you got hold
on. Hold on. Enhance builder define
rule. So rule detail
description event bus default. Yep.
Okay.
Don't think I did it this way. Go back
to
>> advanced
rules. Create news.
Okay.
Rules.
>> Maybe it's
>> maybe tab.
>> Wait, what is rules?
>> Uh, go on to advance folder.
>> Okay.
Yeah, rules.
Rules. Okay. Define rule detail. So,
rule name. Go ahead and put the rule
name in there. Okay.
Yep.
And description. Yeah, default is fine.
Next.
Scroll down.
Uh
[ __ ] Okay.
Yeah, this one use
Wait, where's the schema? Do I have the
schema on here?
H
uh find tokens. Okay, so find token.
Okay, so that's a schema.
>> Uh so that should be Well, hold on. Let
me make sure I got this right. Give me a
second.
>> Okay. To a his ugly head.
>> Yeah, that's Jason, right?
No. Okay. So, it's not JSON. Um,
you it may you may have just written
down what needed to be there as opposed
to
>> so the find tokens that the schema use
click on new schema.
Okay.
Select
scroll up
uh you okay custom
custom
>> but that's a that's a full JSON
>> yeah why I'm looking why didn't I so it
says to find tokens and looking at the
Where is
>> Hey, use Okay, sort of news pattern
form.
>> Okay.
And
uh then AWS service. Click that. Yeah.
Okay. Services is good.
That's fine. Scroll down.
Uh let's go to next.
Yeah. So I thought event pattern. Um put
the purpose in there. say it should be a
JSON format which means some place I did
not copy this correct um use the fine
tokens. So so use equals false and older
than 10 minutes is what that's the
pattern that we're looking for.
Okay so the find tokens uh copy that and
put that into there.
Okay. Um
above says purpose find tokens
>> purpose
>> and pays for.
>> Oh okay I see it.
>> Oh no that's for the lambda isn't it? Oh
god.
>> Yeah. So did you put that into lambda
for
>> I
no I I did not I did not put this into
lambda. Um
this one.
Except maybe
Yeah.
So this is the Lando script here.
Okay. Go back to event bridge. Okay.
And um is the event source supposed to
be other?
I think it's all
uh it should be other custom events.
Okay, this one
second.
Uh, give me a second. Let me go to Demi
real quick.
Uh, give me a second.
Okay. Okay. Hold on. Did you go Let's go
back to
um
when you make the event bridge rules
rule type.
>> Okay. Yeah. Create rule. Mhm.
>> Should I go Should I go back to the to
the homepage?
>> Yeah, let's go back to event bridge.
Let's go back bring it straight to rent
bridge. So,
uh event bridge schedule.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah, there. Click there.
Okay,
>> that makes sense. So instead of the
rule, we just creating schedule and then
oh
we'll type for schedule
currency.
>> You're going to do it every five minutes
and then your target is going to be the
um unused token detector.
Okay.
>> Yep. Rate based.
>> Yeah. Rate based.
So, five minutes.
Yeah.
Oh, there. Yeah. Oh, I know what
happened. Yeah, I I got it. It They
changed the name of the schedule thing.
I didn't put Yeah, that's fine. Yeah,
that's that's fine. That's
>> I'm not trying to point it out to you,
but more so just just I understand I
understand where your mind was. Just not
trying to
>> Yeah.
>> Just supportive D. Supporting Dale.
That's all.
>> Okay. So, time frame D. Right. Okay.
Next. Go to next.
Uh flexible time window five minutes.
Yeah.
Okay. Kra detail going to lambda
lambda.
>> Yeah. AWS lambda
>> and then select
and
that's going to be unused token
detector. Yep. There you go. No, you
don't need that.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah.
>> That should work.
>> Okay.
And that should be it.
Yeah. Let's go down. Create schedule.
Okay, that's what I want.
So I just have to So phase event bridge
schedule. So let's go back to event
bridge.
>> Okay,
>> there it is. event bridge schedule
there. So, I just I just need to say go
to event bridge schedule. That's it.
Okay. That's why that's why that one got
uh derailed derailed.
>> We missed it. It says it right here. We
missed it.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. That's fine. I was
like, what are like, wait, I thought I
got that right.
>> No,
>> no, we didn't read. It's okay. We didn't
read.
>> Okay.
I may edit this right now so I don't
forget.
>> I guess we should also change this to
create schedule too.
>> Yeah. Yeah. That's that's the that's
that's why I pointed out and you know
that that that's why that's where we got
messed up. That's where we got confused.
But again, it was we didn't use all our
all of our contacts to decipher Theo.
So, it's okay.
>> It's fine. That's see this is Yeah. See,
this is 2 o'clock in the morning. Theo
>> work working working session as well.
It's fine.
>> So, yeah, the the details there. So, I
just go ahead and refresh it if you want
to.
>> Okay. know if you want to we have to
>> they have to go so then go down
>> we must
find this
>> need to create a schedule not just
>> okay
>> this works
>> well actually tell you truth the
navigation because it actually just goes
to event bridge and then then it just
goes to event bridge schedule okay so if
It's right there. So, it's fine. All
right. So, you did it.
>> So, it's connected. So, now you need to
trigger or generate the work.
>> Tiqs. We'll do this again tomorrow. And
then we'll also do it on Tuesday.
>> Yeah. This this was this was a new drop.
I thought I thought we were going to do
Cognito rback from Tuesday, but he said,
"No, we're going to do Dynamo DB." Okay,
sure.
This is I think this is more
interesting.
Okay. So you did that.
Okay.
So this should
Okay. So did you generate the the token?
>> I did not.
>> Okay. Go generate a token.
Does this lab build on what we did on
Tuesday with the uh cognito arbback or
can it run without it?
>> So it's arbback that was introduction to
arbback. So now this runs without but
then later on this is our back's going
to come back.
>> Okay. Okay. So so we don't So even if we
even if someone didn't fully do the lab
on Tuesday, they can still run the lab
with last week's infrastructure. Okay.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Okay. Thank you.
>> So our back was this one.
>> So many user pools.
I messed up a few times.
>> That's That's no problem. As long as you
know which one is which. I
>> This one is This one is Tuesdays.
>> Yes,
>> because we have the groups
and we have the users here.
So, actually,
we're just going to reuse this.
I'll bring the terminal over
secret hash. That one is
I think it was
this one.
Okay. What did I do wrong?
I like that. It says Chewbacca
token.
a hundred years from now, people are
going to be talking about, "How did this
Wookie teach this class?"
That's right.
>> Well, they're going to say, "Well, how
did Leiso become an inspiration for so
many people?" You going to have you you
do understand that all the Lisa you've
included in your code is not going to
make her on the level of Mother Teresa?
>> No.
No,
it wasn't my intention. I need I need a
I need a Brazilier stat.
>> Actually, I do need a Brit. Brazilas are
now number one on the list again.
>> Oh. Oh, after So Paulie told you where
to go and he's like, "Hey, that makes
this makes sense."
>> Yeah. So my initial
reservations were validated and he said
like basically
okay this is where the cheating
Brazilians are. This is where they're
not. So there's a distinctions between
the hoes who cheat and the women who are
actually want a husband.
And he gave me really great information
about that. So
that's when Brazil came back.
>> So So did he validate chat GPT and your
conversations with your with your AI
admin?
>> Yeah. So it it validated a lot, but it
got way more precise.
>> Which is what you wanted.
>> Yeah. Which is what I wanted. Yeah. And
um he agreed his this is how he this is
his further definition.
Where do the Americans not go?
>> Yeah,
>> cuz if there aren't that many Americans,
there's probably not that many hosts.
>> I I I saw a real of his uh today where
he says, "Passport bros, if you want to
avoid the greeno areas, go here."
>> So,
>> yeah, it's he's intense on this and I
understand it because that was pretty
much in line with my thought in Tokyo.
You want you want to go to as authentic
Japanese person as you possibly can.
>> Yep.
>> You really want to answer that, Carlton?
>> Oh, man. I I actually read uh Paulie's
Oh, well, I'll give Theo, you can give
the answer because I read something from
Paulie Substack that uh Okay.
>> Go ahead.
>> So,
He he apologized for this first. He says
he could be brutally honest and I said
it's fine because he he's apologize mean
first cuz I'm black. So I said I've been
in Japan we talk I understand like let's
go full passport bro mode because it's
not politically correct when we're
abroad. We actually give real
information.
>> Salvador is out Salvador and Brazil out
of the picture.
>> No. So if I he said if you want part any
kind of dark Brazilian then um espri
espri santos
and if um for Rio if you go across the
peninsula
there's this bridge that goes up to
possibly well where there's there's very
few greeningos so you go further north
from Rio basically to like um Espria
Santos that area you can get darker
women who aren't hopes.
All right. But it says basically outside
of that um
the north almost all of the north of
Brazil is hoe and violet.
And he says I was like yeah I know
that's I I understand the racial imp
implications for this. He's like yeah.
So he's like this is along the coast not
in the interior but along the coast.
this is where you're having the problem.
So he says that's why you have to worry
about kidnapping and things like that.
Also, uh the part
uh are along the border with Argentina
and Paraguay, so I can't go there. I
actually I have to fly over. So he says
worry about the interior. All right.
Yeah. So the Yeah, that's right, Coach.
The place is gorgeous. That's entirely
correct. However,
um
there's there's violence there. He he's
he is honest about it. So if you want
less violence, you need to go south of
Sa Paulo
and but then he's stipulated the
Americans are in Floripa
and it's hoish. They're just a bunch of
hoes there. So it says avoid flurry
and we we went down to specific
information about their yeah they just
put out a lot there just a lot of hose.
So basically
Porto Ogre that's mainly in the Italian
area from that city. If you go a little
bit into the interior, you start getting
really good Italian Brazilians who speak
with a in Portuguese with a slight
Italian accent. And he said basically,
yeah, if you can, there's plenty of them
who aren't hoes who actually just want a
husband. They're, you know, if you speak
the language, you're, you know,
proficient, you're good. And then cuz
he's Polish just so you know. So he he
understands like my Slavic thing. Ki we
talked about that. So uh Kuri Kurybo
Kuriba I think it is.
>> Yeah.
>> Um that's a so north of Floripa but
south of Sa Paulo. Um that's where
there's a lot of Slavic descendants. So
Ukrainians and others. He says yeah
there's barely any Americans there. um
is very boring. It's landlocked, but
there are women there who just want
kids. There's also a lot of Polish women
there. So, they just like they people
just want family. That's it. That's the
big thing. Um boring. Well, we we talked
a lot about how boring is good. That's
what we actually want. Um then his
description of
what as
>> Oh my goodness, that was so useful.
so good. He just is basically like this.
He talked about on the on the the video.
It's just like basically there aren't
any there aren't really that many expats
and the expats are there are main mainly
retirees.
So if you want a stable environment with
women who are very much intrigued that
you're an American
and they're wellendowed like there she's
he's a like a C cup there as a small
breast size
because if you want that kind of stuff
and women who will give birth like who
will eagerly give birth um go to a
sensial.
So, um, someone someone told you this in
the group already. His name is Mike
Nunda. Okay,
>> I'm I'm listening.
>> So,
>> uh, he's he got really really detailed
though, like to which neighborhoods to
go, where my gym should go,
um, like places to avoid, how far out I
go, how the transports will go, that
kind of stuff. I needed I really needed
to have that information. uh import
taxes. He he knew all that kind of
stuff. So, very useful. Um
the next part he said, okay, I'll just
say it to you right now. Um there's a
zillion uh well, Venezuelans there.
So, if you do want a Venezuelan wife,
it's probably one of the better areas to
go to.
>> I can confirm.
>> Yeah.
>> How's your Spanish?
>> Uh I guess I'm learning now, huh? you're
gonna need it down there.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Definitely going to
need it, but they'll the women will go
crazy over you. So, I was like, that's
great. Then then he definitely
emphasized he said like this isn't a
place where you go if if you're going to
be a man [ __ ] Uh if this is this is
family area. So, if you want to be a man
[ __ ] go to Rio or Sa Paulo. Like, just
get it out of your system there. Or go
he said basically anywhere in Colombia.
That's where you do your manhore. But
don't don't go to a place like this
because they're they're not going to
they're not going to look at you too
well if you're if you're being a man
[ __ ] Um and the women are going to
resist. Uh the second now the next part
that he did tell me about was of course
Lima. Um his explanation of Lima was so
different from how other people were
talking to me about Lima. And he was
like basically it has the best food in
all of South America. and he went
through an explanation about that. And
then the best um internal family
structure
and they're just extremely stable in
terms of uh family uh legacy.
Um they don't like affairs, nothing like
that. Uh he we talked to me a lot about
the Chinese population there. Of course,
of course I'm intrigued by that. Of
course, talked about the Japanese
Peruvians, but he's like, "Oh yeah, but
the Chinese are where do you really want
to go?
Um, then that's a second biggest area
for Venezuelans.
So, it told me what neighborhoods to go
for Venezuelans versus uh Chinese. Uh,
there is a race class and there's also a
uh financial class there in Lima. is you
have to worry about it a little bit, but
given my money structure that I have or
if you're making 150,000 as a passport
breaker, you're probably not going to
have to worry about it that much because
you're you're challenging the uh like
the upper 5% of the population there.
So said Lima was is very realistic for
as a place to go.
>> So we So would you say that Lima is like
is is is skyrocketed up to four as a
five or fourth operating base type of
If I want if I want to make a gym and
then I want to basically
a wife who's cheerleading me as I'm
knocking her up,
Lima's one of the best places to go to.
>> You have you basically have a wife and a
daughter who's hope hoping to try to
make a son for her husband and a
grandchild for her father,
right? is that you're not going to
really get like that kind of idea in um
like Colombia for example.
Um yeah, I had a I had a personal
consult with passport
>> multiple.
>> Um so then I had a second one. Um
then he said the the real gem in uh the
area is Cordoba in Argentina
and the architecture is amazing. It's
very quiet, very peaceful
and it's it's something like a boring
Midwest city or a boring like
Scandinavian city. Um and he said
basically this is he said again he very
much emphasized this is for marriage. If
if you're thinking about going there and
being a man [ __ ] this is not for you
but if you want a wife there's there
wives there a lot of them.
So uh there's certain areas where you
don't go. He did talk to me about that.
That was interesting convo like don't go
here don't go here. Um but in terms of
stability, making a company, riding a
bike, things like this, how these are
things I'm import I'm thinking about. Uh
food, culture, things like that. Cordoba
is one of the like hidden gems in the
area. Very few tourists, very stable.
So, uh very much intrigued by all of
that. Uh, but his descriptions of
Brazil, like basically how to avoid
[ __ ] in Brazil, that was like
top-notch.
Very good. Very, very good description.
I was like, I don't want a [ __ ] It's
like, yeah, I don't want one either.
>> So,
does his I'm guessing his advice
basically is a pole opposite of Alex's
advice.
>> Yeah. Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah. Yeah. this A
let's just say that it in Japan we would
have looked funny at Alex
like what's going on because
um normally
like most guys
just find like one Japanese woman
power pump her to death
and then she's so charming you can't
help but marry her,
Right. And the racket that Alex is
doing, he could you can only do that
really in South America. You you or
Thailand, you can do that in the
Philippines. You can't do that in Japan.
Japanese woman would would knock that
[ __ ] out. Just the way it is.
So it's you're you're really talking
about like a Japanese level of
conservatism.
That's really what Paul is,
which I agree. I'm I'm on the same way.
Uh we're we're both very much against um
foreigners coming to the country and
just running through women. It just it
it really ruins the situation.
Rio you basically can't go to if if you
want a family Rio's out
>> really
>> so Paul.
>> So what's what's his opinion on
Colombia? because I Columbia was a a hot
spot for a lot of guys. But uh
>> the the women cheat, he said the women
cheat too much. Um
you get if you do go there, make sure
you get a DNA test on your child. And uh
he says don't even start about Medigene,
but then the Medigene effect is going
through all of Colombia right now. Oh,
so Oh, so it's a it's so just like kesha
culture in the states spreading
>> me the medine whole culture like hey
these women are hot we're going to
really
>> Yeah.
>> Wow.
>> He said he's also complaining about how
um most foreigners
do pay for play in Colombia instead of
actually getting a wife.
>> Yeah.
>> And he he's we we were honest with each
other. He was like, "Why would you want
like like Latinos are pretty hot?
They're pretty beautiful,
>> right?
>> Why would you [ __ ] this? Why you [ __ ] up
the ecos?"
>> Well, why would you want to use a condom
on one?
>> It doesn't make sense. Of course, you're
going to raw duck her, so put a ring on
her and raw dog the hell up. That's That
was my view. That was his view as well.
That's exactly the way we're thinking.
And he says, "So you're you're paying
for box and you have to use a condom
versus one woman who's devoted to you,
loves you, is sexually insatiable,
and wants to be raw dogged constantly.
Like go for that." Like, what is this
pay-for-play [ __ ] We we talked about
that. We were both very critical about
the the pay-per-play. I I don't get it.
I really don't I I don't understand it.
And again, in Japan, the foreigners will
come over sometimes and talk about paper
plan. I'm like, "What the [ __ ] is wrong
with you? Do not understand you people."
>> Um,
>> see,
>> so
>> yeah, go ahead. Go ahead. Keep going.
>> Yeah. So basically um he said if you're
he says where do you go if you're
conservative if you want a wife and
there's basically there's plenty of
women
um
there's there's plenty of women who want
a husband
so just go for them.
He's he's talked about some things in
his videos about his wife. We didn't
talk about his wife directly, but in his
videos, he has said like he basically
had to [ __ ] the stupid out of his wife
more than once, and he just got to get
used to it. That's what that's what the
woman's going to require. And I I mean,
I get it. That's how we talk sometimes
with Japan. You're like, "Yeah, Japanese
wife sometimes just go a little bit
crazy and you just got to [ __ ] her to
death and then she's she's good for a
while,
right?
>> You got to do the the reboot. I just
call it the reboot. do
>> and he's like, "Why would you ever want
to uh
uh do pay for it? Doesn't matter."
>> Um well, I did talk to him a lot about
the Netherlands and Prague about going
there. He gets it. He understands what
the what my goal is and he's like, "Just
go there for a vacation." Um, but if you
if I actually want to marry like like
say I want to marry a Czech woman, it
would I can find the same kind of Slavic
woman in the south of Brazil. The only
difference is that her body count is
ridiculously low, like one or two at
most.
And she basically wants a a finger. She
wants a what is it? A ring on her finger
and to be [ __ ] down by her husband.
it.
It's very basic. It's like that's what
you do. That's that's the best that's
the best solution. Instead, if I go to
Prague and I try to get married in
Prague, I'm probably talking about
marrying going after women who have a
basic body count of 50 and and above.
>> Damn.
This is the stuff you can't talk to
chatp about. It just doesn't work there.
This is the real down low stuff like
yeah these are the [ __ ] these are the
hoes. These are the way things are
going. See, and I I like his perspective
because uh here's so here's a here's the
article I found on his Substack
>> and basically his Substack. He was
talking about how he you know he he's
done the thing like he's done the
hookers and blow. He's done all that and
he he you know talk he documents it
talks about it. That's why he's like
okay I'm I want to sell it down now. So
I I so I get it. I get I I understand
his perspective like um the the arc I
linked has him h is basically you know
he's dealing with Booger Sugar he's
banging chicks that that he has to find
out that they're prostitutes and then
now you know he's getting death threats
from a chick because apparently he
didn't know he had to pay but you know
she still was with the program but
anyways
He's done it. So,
I I mean I I just found his content
interesting on on the on the internet
and then now
now Theo gives the all queer. So, hey,
it's pretty cool.
>> Yeah. Yeah. This so his information
again for if you want a a darker woman,
go there's that area in the north of
Brazil. Go there. But outside of it,
don't. You're just having more more
issues with violence like kind of
something like that. Um, you know, so
you have to
fundamentally
what do you want? That's the big
question. Just what do you want?
>> So,
>> is anything fired?
>> Go to Cloud Watch. It should be there.
>> Um, it's
>> it's even more than what you want. It's
more so um it's not just not just what
you want but in addition it's um what
you want in this new uh containerized
environment because previously it used
to be what you want you could find in
one spot
>> or or in like in in regions of that
singleware spot like like for example
like for all our lives we've known hey
okay what where are the most
opportunities in the US, UK, the West,
right? Now that that's going away, how
do you cobble a new life together with
all these different aspects of different
countries that you want to combine? And
you know, that's where
I I I that's where the the part of my
annoyance, but also part of my
understanding comes in when it comes to
Theo trying to decide where he wants to
go because there's so many variables you
have to tie in and trying to get advice
and trying to see who's worthwhile,
who's not, logistics, a whole lot of
moving parts. And yeah, it seems that
probably has probably be a gateway for
some of us to figure out these more
complex uh uh infrastructures that we
want to build for our own lives.
>> Yeah, you have to be really honest about
it just straight out. Like if if you're
if you're like, "Hey, look, I just want
to go someplace and [ __ ] some chicks."
He's going to tell you where to go. But
so just just so you know, so will half
the class who's and abroad and so will
um Andre or all Guapo, they'll tell you
that because that's what they did,
right? Um but when it comes to getting
marriage, we're talking about something
very different. Did Did it sound off?
Did it work? It looked like it worked.
>> Yeah, I was just exploring the Dynamo DB
page.
>> Okay. But log events
unknown runtime latest.
So it looks like it's working.
So you have Oh no, you have an unhandled
exception.
Ah, but it should be there.
>> There's another um there's another log.
This was just the first listed. So I
need to check the second one.
>> Well, that's unused. So hold on. So the
unused lit token. Okay. That is firing
though.
>> Yes.
>> But it's not going into the database,
right?
>> Let's see. I don't think it is
alarms. No active alarms. Damn.
Uh
Oh
[ __ ]
Okay. Well, I'll troubleshoot that
stuff.
>> Okay.
>> Okay. Fine. So, we're going to work on
this again tomorrow. Um, you can keep
your lambdas up. There's no reason to to
terminate them. Uh, database. Drop that
thing down and
>> we'll go ahead and work on this
troubleshoot. So, this will work. This
is a really cool lab. I want to make
sure this works. Okay. I'm going to keep
on working on this even on Tuesday. All
right.
Right.
>> Okay. So, work on it for entire week.
All right. Uh for some of you guys, I
will see you on the next class. Okay.
Good fun. This was fun. All right. Talk
to you guys later. All right.